Republican congressman
Byron Donalds appeared on Fox News and
this was a disaster of an interview if
I've ever seen one to the point where
even the Fox News host had to come in
and debunk everything he was saying
about the Biden documents versus Trump
documents case of course now multiple
locations classified documents have been
found at Biden's Properties or by and
related properties and that's being
investigated as it should obviously much
less severe than Trump's obstruction and
trying to purposely keep the documents
from the National Archives and that's
why the raid was necessary and we'll
discuss that further but look at this
moment where it just does not go well
and the fox host can't even save Byron
Donald's from his own humiliation had no
problem raiding Mar-A-Lago but let's go
back even before the Mar-A-Lago raid
Donald Trump's attorneys was in
negotiations in talks with the National
Archives they were well aware of what
was happening at Mar-A-Lago so why the
FBI raid you could you you compare that
to what's happened with Joe Biden and
his residents who are yes the FBI was
there but Merrick Garland didn't do his
job at making sure that they were
running the the search and investigation
to make sure everything was found and
secured third question did Joe Biden's
attorneys do they have security
clearance to handle these documents and
continue that search that's a major
question as well yeah well going back to
Mar-A-Lago those negotiations had gone
on for more than a year between the
Department of Justice the Trump uh
organization or not the Trump
organization but the president's
post-presidential organization and the
National Archives and Records
Administration but at some point
president Trump's attorneys told those
entities that all of the documents had
been handed over when that wasn't the
case which is what prompted The Raid so
in terms of the differences here there
do seem to be some but you believe that
there is still a double standard here in
terms of how those two things were
handled
oh absolutely without a doubt because
here's the other thing you get leaks to
the Press pictures of documents trust
all over the floor so then he just jumps
to a completely different thing okay so
even though both of them stayed calm and
talked professionally that was just so
um I guess the word that she keeps
coming to mind is humiliating or
embarrassing because Byron Donald is
trying to go with this new narrative
from the right wing that listen our
concerns not about the classified
documents at the end of the day or I am
concerned but that's not the main
concern the real concern is the double
standard we cannot have a two-tier
justice system in the United States and
nothing proves that we have that more
than the fact that Trump was raided and
Biden wasn't
and so we're going to discuss why that's
so absurd but let's kind of step back
for a second and walk through the
timeline
as we built up to this the Trump
Mar-A-Lago situation was going on the
documents there a lot of the right wing
Fox News Republicans were just covering
for Trump defending him
saying this was Witch Hunt then the
Biden document story breaks before any
of the right wing is able to get a read
on how the left is going to respond how
Democrats are going to respond they
immediately say see nobody cares when
it's spied and everyone cares when it's
Trump
and then
every single Democrat minus a few that
I've seen and as you know in a wholesale
sense I guess the left has been very
much okay with investigations into Biden
and if there's wrongdoing absolutely
hold the proper people accountable based
on the documents we also make clear that
there's a big difference between the
Trump and Biden document situation for
sure it's dishonest to pretend that
there's not but there was no don't talk
about that don't talk about that as they
told us there would be so then I watched
as kind of they had to work up a new
talking point to keep with the double
standard before it was the left's going
to cover up Biden and talk about Trump
then they realized nobody's trying to
cover up and not talk about Biden so now
it's the double standard is Trump was
rated Biden wasn't
but they never go one step further and
try to think about
why that might be do you think raids are
necessary in every single investigation
are raids necessary every single time
documents are in the wrong place no The
Raid was necessary for Trump because he
obstructed time and time again the
national archives from getting the
documents they were requesting and
requesting as the Fox News house had to
come in and say there and Trump
knowingly lied and kept the documents
um which is why they had to eventually
after being incredibly patient raid
Mar-A-Lago
Biden immediately him and his team have
complied have turned over the documents
when they came across them and are fully
on board complying with the
investigation
why would a raid be necessary explain
that to me why would a rape be necessary
genuinely very very strange make sure
you are subscribed to the David Pacman
show uh YouTube channel and I have a
show of my own of course today I'm
filling in for David while he's away but
if you like what you're saying you go to
Luke Beasley on YouTube link in the
description on YouTube
um and I'll see you after a quick break